he'll come for me he's tried before many
times with many three-eyed Ravens
Dragonfire will stop him I don't know no
one's ever tried hi everyone it's
Charlie this is gonna be my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 2 Q&A video
covering a night of the Seven Kingdoms
in the episode 3 trailer video we're
doing Game of Thrones videos all season
long if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything
I'll be talking about the prequel TV
series the game of Thrones is doing
that's supposed to premiere next year
when we get a little bit closer to the
end of the season 2 we're still doing
the HBO now giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video careful for
spoilers for everything through episode
2 in the episode 3 trailer video first
one Mariana asks do you think that
Barrack will resurrect someone in the
next episode so you're talking about the
kiss of life twist from the books there
have been a lot of questions on my
videos about whether or not they're
gonna pull a Lady Stoneheart twist from
the books using Barracks kiss of life
just using a different character instead
of Catelyn Stark Barrack is on my death
predictions list so I think either way
he probably goes during this episode
it's possible but not probable that he
uses the kiss of life to bring one of
the other big characters back careful
for spoilers from the books I'll just
explain the kiss of life twist so I have
to explain Lady Stoneheart briefly what
happens in the books is a long time
after the red wedding beric Dondarrion
finds the body of Catelyn Stark that's
been decomposing on a riverbank he
brings her back to life by essentially
passing his life force into her creating
Lady Stoneheart but because her body's
been decomposing for a long time and she
has all these giant gash wounds all over
her because of what happened to her
during the red wedding and because she's
been dead for so long it's almost a pet
cemetery twist where she's a little bit
crazy she barely remembers her life
before she became Lady Stoneheart
and goes on this crazy vengeance quest
so it's very different from what we got
on the TV show and I'm not expecting
them to do a whole lot of that this late
in the game but it is possible
next one Lima Nell asks will you talk
about the potential deeper meaning
behind Jenny's song or the theories
surrounding it
for example the theory that Rhaegar was
the one who wrote it and potentially
sang it to the ghost of the high heart
so yes there is a lot of deeper meaning
to Jenny's song but the TV show added
some of their own lyrics
to it the song itself is actually
supposed to be about the tragedy at
summer hall where Aegon v in his entire
family died in a fire but because of the
way they used the song with the John
Snow Daenerys reveal at the end of the
episode where he tells her the truth
a lot of the deeper meaning of the song
for shadows what might end up happening
between the two of them later this
season Jenny of old stones was a
commoner who fell in love with the crown
prince of Aegon v his name was Duncan
Targaryen he was named Duncan the small
after Aegon's best friend Duncan the
tall remember the title of the episode
was a knight of the Seven Kingdoms all
about Brienne being knighted by Jaime a
knight of the Seven Kingdoms is the name
of the book compendium of the tales of
Duncan egg Duncan the tall and Aegon v
so it gets really meta but what happened
is is that Duncan when he fell in love
with Jenny of old stones was forced to
give up his crown in order to be with
her which he did so a lot of people
wondered if that meant that Jon Snow
would give up his claim on the Iron
Throne
to be with Daenerys but here's the twist
I think that implies more about what
Daenerys is going to give up to be with
Jon Snow but the person that she truly
loves because she's the one that wants
this thing so badly Jon Snow never
wanted the Iron Throne Kit Harington in
real life after the episode was saying
John doesn't bloody want any Iron Throne
or any crown so it's not so much about
him giving things out that wouldn't be
very meaningful because he'd do it in a
second he hasn't even asserted any
potential claim to the Iron Throne to
begin with it'd be much more meaningful
if Daenerys gave up the thing that she
had fought so hard for which I think
just implies that at the end of the
series she's going to give up her quest
for the Iron Throne I don't even think
there's gonna be an Iron Throne by the
end so the visions she has from the
house of the undying where she's almost
touching the Iron Throne
I think them using the Jenny of oldstone
song in the story of Jenny of old stones
is just paying reference back to that
moment the Daenerys will come within
grasp of her goal but she'll give it up
for Jon Snow in a family with him there
are a lot of people that are wondering
if it means if Daenerys is going to
sacrifice her life to save Jon Snow the
person that she loves but I don't think
we should take it that far I think this
is more just about the Iron Throne
because for her that's her endgame at
this moment but she's in love with Jon
Snow
she might potentially get pregnant with
his child so that would complicate
matters there's still a lot of big
twists with their situation that they
could throw
in the next couple of episodes hopefully
that explains a little about Jenny's
song from the books but remember the TV
show created those lyrics so those
lyrics aren't from the books the actual
lyrics just pay more reference to the
tragedy of summerhall with Jenny dancing
with the ghosts talking about the ghosts
of her family that died in the tragedy
so when a broad level it applies to all
the characters on the show not wanting
to leave their loved ones but I don't
think it really goes too much further
than that they just want you to think
that most of these characters are gonna
die and they don't want to leave each
other so this is like their last moment
to say goodbye to each other we could
talk about Jenny's song all day but next
one thug life ass how about a video
detailing the extent of John and Danny's
forces stationed at Winterfell and the
combined numbers Northman Mormont's
manderlys Dothraki unsullied wildlings
Greyjoy's Knights of the Vale and any
other forces that might show up for the
battle when you combine John and
Daenerys as forces they still have a
little bit less than the army of the
Dead before they made it south of the
wall the army the dead had about a
hundred thousand White's and that just
included animals as well as just regular
people that had been turned into whites
you have to assume by the time they get
to Winterfell they picked up a couple
more because you have the UM bird you
have a bunch of other potential
stragglers they picked up as far as John
Anthony IRS's forces the north has about
45,000 available troops that includes
the Knights of the Vale you assume that
numbers gotten whittled down a little
bit since Battle of the bastards so say
like a little under 50,000 Daenerys also
used to have around 50,000 troops and
that included the Dothraki bloodrider x'
and her unsullied so assume their
combined forces are around 90,000 maybe
a little bit less than that but they
also have two dragons the nike only has
one so even though the army of the Dead
has the advantage and just sheer numbers
they want to make it seem like Jonathan
Ayers forces have a chance of beating
them but the minute that the White
Walkers are the whites start killing
their troops they instantly raise them
back up as whites so the army of the
Dead begins to grow exponentially during
the battle if they don't start burning
the bodies immediately which would be
really interesting to see how they
handle during the episode number 9fo
asks when will Cersei lose the baby yeah
they pretty much confirmed that there
really is a baby she'll probably lose it
later this season I'm guessing not to
the last couple of episodes the way
they're pitching episode 3 is that it's
all this battle but that doesn't mean
that you won't see characters from other
places in Westeros show up during the
episode remember we could get a couple
surprised appear
during the battle but I'm not expecting
a whole lot of cersei stuff till episode
4 and that's when they'll start to carry
forward the baby arc because she was
kind of hinting at it when you're on had
his hand on her belly and was talking
about putting a baby in her I wouldn't
be surprised if they pushed that to tail
end episode 4 or sometime during episode
5 but we'll find out pretty soon next
one it's over 10s what do you think is
gonna happen to John and Daenerys
relationship now that she knows he's a
Targaryen do you think that she's
pregnant yeah I think that's another
thing we'll find out about real soon
whether or not she's actually pregnant
the news is obviously driven a wedge
between them but the thing is is
Daenerys is not worried about the fact
that he's related to her she was ready
to marry her brother Viserys before Khal
Drogo came along she actually did assume
that she would marry him because it was
Targaryen custom to Wed sister to
brother so the fact that they share
blood has nothing to do with why she's
so angry it's all about his potential
claim to the throne she thinks that he
wants the throne which is obviously
bullcrap he doesn't want have anything
to do with that so a lot of it is just
drama in the moment to complicate what's
happening during episode 3 because of
this big battle so I don't think they're
gonna address it a lot till we get to
episode 4 but obviously as we head into
the finale and they actually do get
their sites literally on the Iron Throne
then they'll start resolving things
she'll probably find out that she's
potentially pregnant and that would
really be the thing to want Jon Snow to
repair their relationship because he
hates the idea of bastards and if
they're not married when that baby is
born then that baby would be a bastard
but a lot of that is still so far off in
the distance that will talk about that
woman's to get to like episode 4 episode
5 next one sorry I don't know how to
pronounce your name but you asked isn't
the night king able to only revive the
dead only when they are freshly killed
so he couldn't revive the dead in the
crypts so a lot of people have asked
about this I don't think they're gonna
go for that twist as much but that
doesn't mean that they're completely
safe in the crypts most of the dead in
the crypts are skeletons in Ned Stark's
skeleton for instance has the head
separated from the body so we don't
think we're gonna see a headless Ned
Stark running through the crypts after
all these people hiding down there but
we're the whites could do is they could
tunnel in from other places around the
crypts the way they tunneled into the
root system of the three-eyed Ravens
trade they didn't even bother to go in
the front door so the whites could do
that that would probably be their way in
next one you Jenny asks do
see Danny's face when Jamie mentioned
the golden company so she's just shocked
at the idea that Circe will have enough
forces to defeat them after this big
battle because these are gonna lose so
many of their troops we haven't seen a
whole lot of them in action recently so
I wouldn't be surprised if there was a
quote-unquote golden surprise sometime
in the next couple of episodes because
they wouldn't hype them up that much
during season seven oh the golden
company you got to watch out for them
they're gonna be awesome there's 20,000
of them they're super badass they've
never broken a contract just expect
something from them really really soon
next one Diana asks do you think there's
gonna be a wedding this season so I
don't know if we have enough time for an
actual wedding if they do like full
return of the king Lord of the Rings
style with John and tenaris but I think
they're hinting at that if they both
survive I think those are just imply
that in the future that's what they're
going to do like I said Jon Snow hates
the idea of bastards if she potentially
becomes pregnant with his child he would
feel honorbound Ned Stark style to get
married to her regardless of what kind
of dramas between them at that point but
just remember that the show does not
trade on happy endings but I think we're
all hoping that the finale is titled a
dream of spring which is kind of a
hopeful title for the finale like maybe
things will potentially get better even
if it's not quite so simple
next one bad spy asks where's the best
character in all of Game of Thrones
history I mean we didn't even see him
much last season so you're talking about
ghosts yeah we barely saw him during the
episode if you blinked you may have
missed him but he was standing with them
when they were all talking about their
time in the Nights Watch about Samwell
the Slayer lover of ladies what does the
world come to you see very good boy
ghost
off in the background just sort of
nodding his head he doesn't even look
that big a lot of people like how come
ghost isn't bigger and frame he just
seems like he should be huge at this
point I think this is the show saying
that we just couldn't figure out a
really easy way to do this they've never
been good with the visual effects of the
direwolf so they've completely avoided
them in favor of the Dragons I'm
assuming the ghost will be present
during the battle maybe they'll have him
do something cool my expectations for
that are low
next one quandra asks do you think we'll
see any of brands warg powers in episode
3 maybe Jon doesn't write a dragon and
bran wargs into it I would love that
twist I do think the brains gonna try
and use his work abilities I mean he's
just another tool on this Arsenal for
fighting the army of the Dead and
helping them people have been asking
George or Martin if you could work a
dragon for as long as the books had been
out
he said that there's no precedent for it
so when they asked brand in the episode
if dragon fire could hurt the night king
and he said we don't know no one's ever
tried it I think that was a bit of a
wink to the idea that they're gonna try
a few things that no one has ever tried
before with his abilities during the
episode so he has high probability that
he tries to work one of the Dragons
during the episode we'll see if he does
how successful that winds up being
because I don't think that any of the
battle is gonna go the way that he
thinks it will thank you so much for so
many questions everyone these are always
fun to do I'll be doing these for all
the episodes this season there's so much
stuff happening this weekend Avengers
end game is coming out I'll be doing
videos for that obviously my episode 3
video will post Sunday night leave all
your requests for other bonus videos in
the comments below
congratulations to the winner from the
last big giveaway Vance Wallis please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your details while you wait
for everything click here for my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 3 trailer video
and click here for my season 8 episode 2
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight